طعام صحي طعام ضار
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لالا
لا لا لا لا
هيا نعرف يا صغار الأكل الصحي والضار
أنواع شتى نأكلها فلا تحتار لا تحتار
لا تحتار لا تحتار
أنا مشروبات غازية *** وأنا إسمي بطاطا مقلية
وأنا حلوى وعصائر *** زاهية اللون صناعية
لا لا لا لا لا لا هذا طعام ضار
لا لا لا لا لا ويسبب الآلام
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا ليست صحية
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا تبنى الأجسام
طعام صحي طعام ضار
أنا تفاحة وأنا موز حمص بندق جوز ولوز
فاكهة ومكسرات لحم أو خُضر وأرز
صحية تلك الأكلات فاكهة  خضروات
والماء ضروري نشربه دوما  كل الأوقات
طعام صحي يبنى جسمي يعطيني طاقة يومي
يدفع عني كل ضرر يحميني من كل سقم
طعام صحي طعام ضار طعام صحي طعام ضار
خيار مع خس مع ماء والكوسا نطبخها حساء
بصل مع ثوم مع فلفل يدفع عنا كل الداء
طعامك في كل الوجبات تتخيره في الأكلات
جميل في الطعم وشهي يجعلك كالبطل قوي
هيا نعطى الأولوية في وجباتنا اليومية
نتخير أي الأصناف تلك النافعة الصحية
طعام صحي طعام ضار طعام صحي طعام ضار
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لالا
لا لا لالا
هيا نعرف يا صغار الأكل الصحي والضار
أنواع شتى نأكلها فلا تحتار لا تحتار
لا تحتار لا تحتار